attorney general merrick garland is
calling on attorneys around the country
to volunteer and help people at risk of
being evicted
the legal profession is well positioned
to provide support for tenants landlords
and courts during this crisis
ensuring that our justice system
delivers outcomes that are fair and
accessible to all
without regard to wealth or status
is one of the highest ideals of our
profession
garland suggested that attorneys
volunteer with their local legal aid
provider or volunteer to mediate for the
courts on thursday the supreme court
struck down the eviction moratorium
extended by the cdc saying it must be
passed by congress
well the i-team has been covering
housing issues throughout southern
nevada and according to metro there was
a very slight dip in the number of
eviction notices delivered by the
constables office over the past couple
of weeks i hear the numbers from august
15 to the 21st the department reports
169 the following week 162 reported
vanessa murphy shared the story of one
woman who was evicted and eight news now
viewers responded with generosity
this gate was locked when karine cantino
was evicted she says she slept in her
car with her pets but thanks to some
generous eight news now viewers she is
now back in her home with her pets no
longer homeless karine
tell me what this experience has been
like for you
i am so grateful
for this lady that wants to remain
anonymous
she helped me tremendously and the power
of prayer is amazing
is amazing i am so blessed that she came
and helped me like she did she told us
she's a former metro employee but she
doesn't want to be named she came
forward and donated more than eight
thousand dollars and then there's also
this this gofundme which was over five
thousand dollars from other viewers i i
can't thank the people enough for for
helping me as much as they have
i really i owe you a big thank you
from all my heart i i just thank you i
appreciate you you're all earth angels a
new beginning for you and your pets
thanks for sharing your story thank you
vanessa thank you so much
you're welcome thank you we'll send it
back to you
karine contino by the way says one of
the issues she faced was just navigating
the whole rental assistance program also
known as chap and then getting answers
while she waited for her application to
be processed the i-team reached out to
the county and a spokesman says 8 500
applications are still waiting to be
processed we have information to help
both tenants and landlords at eight
newsnow dot com